welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who's had a couple of nights out
that have ended with some mortal kombat
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing the movie's plot ending the
new characters in it
and also where things could be heading
if we get a sequel
full spoilers ahead so if you want to
finish it before knowing what happens
then i highly recommend that you get out
of here that's really bad that's a
really bad joke and i apologize for that
but please click the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into mortal kombat
okay so we're going to be discussing
some big plot points in the movie as i
feel that we need to address those
before diving into the end
but if you want to skip ahead then time
codes will be linked below
although scorpion initially started off
as a bad guy in the series
as the video game franchise has gone on
he slowly changed from a villainous
viper head into one of its best
anti-heroes
we begin in 17th century japan at the
home of hanzo hazashi
and see the man who would later become
him have his son and wife killed
maybe you should get over here hey now
this is carried out by bihan
a man who would later go on to become
sub-zero the mortal enemy of scorpion
in the game cannon hanzo was one of the
finest warriors in his ninja clan
and he was a master at hand-to-hand
combat as well as using a rope and
dagger
now bihan and hanzo go head to head in
the opening of the movie
and the former bests him murdering him
in the process
as hanzo dies he hears the cries of his
daughter
who is saved by the thunder god and
appointed protector of earth realm
raiden
hanzo's soul descends into the nether
realm and from the game we know that
it's here where his spirit became a
vengeful specter
hell bent on just stice now over the
centuries
scorpions sought vengeance on those that
murdered his family
and this led to him working with
villains like quan chi he's one of the
most
interesting characters in the entire
franchise and from the top i absolutely
love the authenticity that this movie
brought with it
starting it off in japan was an inspired
choice and it really gave the movie some
grit to it
though he doesn't appear in the film
that much he's still one of its key
characters
and arguably the most important person
in it now the movie primarily focuses
around the outworld
who are now close to crushing earth
realm due to achieving nine consecutive
wins against their champions in the
mortal kombat tournament
should they win the 10th they'll make
2020 look like 1999
and thus the forces of shang tsung will
do whatever they can to ensure victory
we join call young an ex-mma champion
who is haunted by
visions of hanso possessing the mark of
the dragon
he becomes very important to the plot
it's revealed that cole is actually a
descendant of hanzo
and for centuries there's existed a
prophecy that stated that his blood will
unite a new generation of earth-run
fighters
that will protect the planet aware of
this prophecy shang tsung sends out his
forces to kill
all of the earthrealm champions which
can be identified by their distinctive
dragon marks
he wants to win before the game even
begins and i love how this character who
was pretty much a cheat in the games
was also a cheat in this story a bit of
a reach there but i appreciated it now
young is a brand new character for the
series
that has seemingly replaced johnny cage
much to the dismay of fans
though i know a lot of people are angry
over this we do get a tease towards
johnny at the end of the film
and i think that with the tone they're
going for the switch-up definitely feels
right
the movie's director simon mccoy said
that cage was very much a 90s action
star parody
i know that works with the game in the
original film i feel this update makes
more sense and i'm a guy who used to
love
hoofing him in the balls when he tried
to kick me now we'll discuss the new
version at the end of the video but
hopefully he doesn't leave you with a
coal
shoulder which is both a coal pun and a
sub-zero one so
that's not as bad as the other ones in
this video now played by lewis tan
you might recognize him from the netflix
show wu assassins i think he does a
great job in this movie
though new characters introduced into
films based on long-standing franchises
often suck
tan works really well as a protagonist
in my opinion
now they don't mind also throwing big
names from the franchise at the screen
thick and fast
and after running into jacks cole is
pointed in the direction of sonia blade
here she explains the dragon mark can be
transferred by killing someone who bears
it
and this is how both jacks and kano
managed to get one
amongst stair files we also catch a
glimpse of nightwolf a character from
the series that taught liu kang how to
perform a bestiality
not like that if you filthy animal now
reptile attacks her base
and after kano kills the beast by
getting it toasty
the group journey across the sky and
desert to ryden's temple
along the way we meet the other
protectors in liu kang and kung lao
who hats off looks completely awesome
here they're protected from shang
tsung's forces by a powerful barrier
and the group trained to unlock their
signature moves which are called arcanas
after cole is unable to master his
raiden informs him of his ancestors and
sends him home
more disappointing than i was when the
movie didn't start with the mortal
kombat theme tune
they do bring it in at the end though
now at this point shang tsung pulls
together his best assassins in mylena
nitara cabal riko and prince goro
gabal an ex-associate of kano was
betrayed by the character
and left in what he refers to as a
walking iron lung
the machine man knows that kano's got
more faces than shang tsung
and thus he offers him a deal to bring
down the barrier so that they can attack
kano betrays them and goro storms cold's
home
against him coal manifests his arcana
which is a powerful suit of armor and
weapons that absorb
energy though he doesn't fully disarm
goro he's still left pretty armless
and i love this moment when they burst
out several fatalities from the game
including kung lao's spinning hatsu move
raiden reveals that he actually wanted
shang tsung's forces to attack
so that coal aka the chosen one could
find his arcana
and that the prophecy is now fulfilled
sadly before he can pull off a hat-trick
kung lao is killed and in the void
between realms the forces regroup
after getting hanzo's got intro well as
blade from raiden
cole realizes that they have to enforce
the rules in order to beat the bad guys
and in one-on-one arenas that feel like
they were ripped straight out of the
game
[ __ ] goes down it's own the fight scenes
are absolutely amazing
and they really managed to recapture the
look and feel of the fatalities for
these moments
there were several i recognized from
when my little sister be i mean when i
won the arcade tournament
and i love how they kept the film as
close to the game as they could
it really shines in these battles making
it arguably one of the best video game
movies of all time
wasn't that hard though but after sonia
kills kano and gets his dragon mark
the rest of the fighters are taken down
which leaves just sub-zero left
he captures cole's family after
surprising them
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
as they become isolated
in a frozen prison still got it now
though he loses what i'd consider round
one if it was in the game
cole uses hanzo's blade on the villain
which summons his spirit from the nether
realm
i'm sure they redubbed the get over here
from the original trailer
and it is possible that series creator
ed boon provided it
as it sounds way closer to how it is in
the game
working together scorpion and cole
managed to kick some ice
and they beat sub-zero in the ladder's
old mma arena
scorpion unleashes his fire breath in
what is one of the character's signature
moves
this transforms half of his face into
the skull that is synonymous with the
character
and though it heals i appreciate this
little nod to the source material
he returns to the underworld having
avenged his family
and he entrusts cole to look after the
bloodline now similar the game
shang tsung loses the tournament and
though his champions have been defeated
he hatches a new plan to return with the
armies of outworld
raiden knows that other enemies are
coming and he says that they must
assemble some new champions
the first of those being a hollywood
actor known as johnny cage
obviously cage is a big name in the
series and was very surprised that he
wasn't in this entry
cage was a struggling action movie star
that entered the tournament to
revitalize his career
and in doing so he would prove his
abilities to skeptical fans
that didn't believe he was the one
behind the stunts cage is very
materialistic when we first meet him
but over the years in games he did lose
much of this persona
and became someone who was completely
dedicated to defending earth
now going off the storyline of the
original it's likely that we will
encounter emperor shao khan
at some point in the sequel in the
second game xiao khan was furious that
shang
tsung failed and thus he decided to lure
the earth realm warriors to outworld
the stakes were changed and if
earthrealm won
they would be left alone however if they
lost then our world would be able to
regain the prior 9 wins
count the new one as 10 and invade the
planet with nothing to stop them
though the outlook was bad liu kang
managed to best can in combat with a k
and i can see this being the main
storyline that they tackle in the sequel
in the 2011 reboot though we followed
the bare bones of the original plotline
there are certain elements injected into
it such as visions of the future
that showed a timeline in which all was
lost now because of his inclusion in the
film and the fact that marlena is a
clone of his daughter katana
i can see kan being the next big bad
there was also another character who was
said to be part of the film
but simon mccoy ended up cutting him out
now that was rain
in case you don't know rain is a very
much the water version of raiden
and throughout the series we've
discovered that he's a demigod
upon learning this in his personal
ending the character decided to build up
an army to conquer all the realms
it's interesting that he was originally
in the film as this is of course very
similar to what shang tsung wanted to do
at the end
potentially rain could end up getting a
big role in the next movie
and if he was cut from this one then i
can imagine that he might be in the
roster come next time
now as for my thoughts on the film i
have to say i really enjoyed it
after seeing the first trailer i was a
bit meh on the designs and new character
focus
but i think the film works really really
well i also absolutely love kano
hilarious hilarious now though we don't
get big back stories for the characters
and the plot is pretty predictable what
we're here for is of course the
over-the-top gore
and martial arts it doesn't disappoint
in that department at all
and there were so many scenes i was sat
open mouth thinking
i can't believe they've actually managed
to bring this to the big screen
now mortal kombat was great and i really
enjoyed it
it's definitely one of the best video
game movies ever made and it's a strong
step forward for setting up a franchise
of films based around different
characters and tournaments
mortal kombat was great and it gets a 7
out of 10.
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the movie so make sure you comment
below and let me know as
a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
during the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like it make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
falcon in the winter soldier which will
be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the final episode and
discussed everything you need to know
about it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care
and get out of here i'm sorry i couldn't
resist goodbye